everybody Sean McKenna's here at PAX
Prime 2014 I've got Sam Robinson the
lead level designer on stealth Inc to
that we're checking out for the wii u
right now Sam obviously you guys did
stealth Inc which was very interesting
to d take on the stealth genre what do
you guys trying to do with stealth this
time around this time around we're
trying to pull back and give the player
much richer experience in the last game
because the last game was just a kind of
a very basic kind of game didn't have
much of a narrative it was all level
based one off the other this time around
we have an entire exploratory world it's
kind of like a Metroidvania game where
you go out and get gadgets and you go
back to the exploratory world and you
can discover more and so is it is it one
big open space where like levels are
kind of locked until you get a
particular item and then that unlocks a
new part and you just kind of progress
through like that way basically you're
burek alone born into a massive facility
where they tests children's toys in a
very sadistic way and i'd imagine all
children's toys are tested in a sadistic
way and at the beginning of this game
you actually escape the testing
procedures like you escape the testing
area which the entire last game was set
in so you escaped this horrible place
and you break out into the pti facility
where this is all going on and you get
to explore why they're doing these tests
this way and you discover that you're
one of millions of clones yeah and you
as you progress through the game you
find out they're testing more than just
your stealth covers the whole last game
was based around the stealth goggles in
this game we do you discover that
they're testing way more bizarre toys
like a bizarre toy line and you can
unlock all these toys and then come back
into the exploratory world and they help
you unlock new areas and discover the
rest of the game
so give me a sense of the overall
progression where are we at right now in
terms of the whole arc so we have just
been born in the clone lab it's the end
of the day and there's a quality
controller and he's a bit of a jobsworth
he's competing with his colleagues and
he wants to higher score because if you
could I get points for doing these tests
and so you've just been born to complete
the test at the end of the day but the
problem is the end of the day kind of
butter alarm went off and the facility
is now shutting down and they're kind of
cleaning the testing literature the test
chambers of all clones yet so they're
trying to annihilate you about right now
basically
you know just nice light-hearted stuff
oh yeah absolutely i mean it's done in a
kind of cute way that we do get a teen
rating for this one I think we made the
clones a bit more human looking the last
time I mean I personally I don't see any
problem with tiny little clone people
getting eviscerated by deadly lasers but
maybe that's just me they play a much
bigger role in this game because they're
actually all that because it's the end
of the day and all the test chambers are
shutting down once you break out you
realize that there are other clones
trapped in all the other test chambers
so by going into the test chambers
you're rescuing the clones so every test
chamber now has clones hidden about it
and you have to rescue them so that's
kind of your motivation for going around
the tests and so clearly you guys are
still doing that kind of a text on the
wall style storytelling so in the last
game we had these projections and the we
originally put those into tutorial the
player and also kind of abuse them for
when they made a mistake that kind of
thing this time we pull back and we show
you who's writing that text so the cue
the Quality Controller his name's
Malcolm in the opening cutscene he's the
one that's typing these messages to you
so he wants at the moment he's just
trying to get rid of you he's had enough
and he wants to go home and you're
causing all kinds of problems for him
and he becomes easier antagonist for the
whole game basically and here he becomes
very irate with you oh no relationship
with him he's a cruel man so here he is
so now he's realizing that you've
escaped and everything and he has to
deal with you
and thanks to the magic of editing
software here we are just skip straight
forward we've skipped to chapter 2 so
all of the chapter 1 is about the
stealth goggles because you know it's
great it's great mechanic and it's mean
we it's something that you're gonna use
about the game but now we're in chapter
2 so we actually introduced the gadgets
in the last game we had gadgets but you
unlock them after the fact after the
levels and you could go back and replay
them but they didn't really have any use
in this game have to use the gadgets to
progress like they're an integral part
of the game so this one's the first ones
the inflator make and you can throw this
thing around and you can retrieve it
when you place it you can grow it looks
like this little blob this guy that
inflates so you can use them to get up
to new areas like this you can also
throw it and kill an enemy by dropping
on them you can also use as a
springboard like you gangsters like that
so I can use it to springboard but I can
also call it back to me oh no let me do
the skin and you can do it in midair
like I can keep doing it over and over
so I can kind of fly around and it
becomes very acrobatic so you can just
imagine that once you've completed this
chap then you go back into the
exploratory world this gives you a great
deal of freedom which you can basically
fly around and discover loads of new
places let me just place these ones
levels I would imagine that a gadget
like this could be both fun and very
challenging for you as a level designer
right absolutely yeah
I mean we're so used to making these
levels now and they've got the guys that
we had making lovers for us then they
were stealth Inc one veteran's yeah so
we know all the things not to do but
there's definitely a prototyping phase
when we come up with these gadgets and
we have to test to make sure they're
actually fun but it was quite quick to
do actually because we actually
prototype this will win Game Maker yoyo
games game makers it was really quick
and dirty to do and then it all got kind
of a portal a new engine so I can use to
wait on switches like that as a pressure
switch here which turns off this green
containment field so I'm just go up
there switch is down there you can see
that i can use it to obstruct laser
beams and past and everything oh my
goodness everything has a dual use
that's the way we make our mechanics
everything has to have at least a dual
use because I just gives a really kind
of rich game plan that's really good for
making puzzles okay these are these blue
equipment of filter always retrieval
casualties I didn't have to bring it
back to you so this guy down here if I
just drop it round kill em so that
overclan run one switch if the santee of
perhaps played this level before I have
played this level many many times so
this is a good example so in the lower
right corner we've got a clothed as a
clone in this level somewhere which we
don't know where he is I know areas
clues over here so if i find this secret
switch here you then discover a clone
and then i have to use this inflator
mate down there and I can get him out
and now I've rescued a clone and now
he'll will appear in to the
exploratorium
yes yeah cool sorry yeah probably good
sorry I have no sense of how much
violence of wasting that's great i think
know we've got we're making good time
this guy's just really good every Thomas
all right we skipped forward a little
bit here to a another gadget Sam what
and the heck is going on here skip to
chapter 5 and this is a really kind of
weird gadget is the me too and they
always gadgets controlling the same way
so I can throw this over here and I can
initiate the thing I can turn it on and
it's another one of me i so i can create
to clone simultaneously and i can
control them simultaneously what i can
do is i can kill myself and then I take
control of the other clone so the levels
have got much harder by this point but
now I can actually kill myself over and
over and over and I don't have to worry
about the consequences it's quite
liberating let's keep showing myself to
progress I have to do it to the best you
I don't want to say this but I feel like
you're sacrificing a little bit of your
humanity every time you die and jump
over to new character yes it's just
slightly it's slightly against the
narrative of the game but it's so funny
that it sits in staying and we have to
do it so here oh right I just throw that
okay confused so throw him over there I
turn him on so now offer the coin in the
sensor beam but I have to run right a
left over here to kill myself so I tell
him or I'll turn back on and now this is
my primary clone so I can spare me yeah
and the lettin the levels become really
kind of confusing doing this but so you
feel like a genius by the end you I mean
you were in lying before when you said
that you have to condition players to
know that they're gonna die yes yes
absolutely yeah yeah but it's hilarious
is absolutely hilarious but you can just
keep blowing
you're like the most sadistic thing you
could do is put like an achievement in
there for a no deaths run through image
it's impossible there is actually in
there's actually a ranking system so you
get a rank at the end of every level and
if you haven't died very at all in fact
you'll get an s-rank you haven't been
spotted by enemies you'll get an s-rank
it's also time-based we have
leaderboards as well so you can compete
online leaderboards with everybody yeah
I always get stuck at this bits are you
you know I'll let you focus oh no oh no
that's that teen rating in place Sam
thank you so much for your time can you
just go ahead and reiterate for players
out there what your release plans are in
terms of platforms and timing so I still
think too is an exclusive to Wii U and
it's going to come out on the opto on
October the 23rd on the Nintendo eShop
thank you very much thank you very much
for coming
you